talons qu'il a il faut qu'il revienne
parmi le top 10 messieurs le top 10 en
yeah allez moins de kilomètres avant
l'arrivée le premier giratoire vampire
bien réalisé par ces deux garçons Dylan
will de la Croix du Sud bred Matoury et
Jean-Emmanuel lorendo de la sélection de
Martinique Dylan will 22e à 2 minutes 33
le resto à 49
5 minutes et c'est parti pour le premier
giratoire
c'est fait maintenant une difficulté
technique c'est l'épingle à cheveux
messieurs et puis ensuite la ligne
droite direction l'arrivée pour ces deux
garçons la victoire sera
martiniquaise
à nouveau Dylan qui se ouais voilà c'est
négocié et c'est parti pour le swing
allez c'est parti pour le sprint avec
vous le disiez je vais Emmanuel de la
sélection de la Martinique qui s'est
relevé déjà sur sa bicyclette qui va
continuer son effort et qui va
certainement franchirer oui un grand
vainqueur la ligne d'arriver à
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni après plus de 3
heures et 12 minutes